aktion irrt nicht ist das reine
koketterie oder etwa selbsterkenntnis
franz ferdinand und spox zwei bands zwei
generationen und ein gemeinsamer sinn
für humor
der zeigt sich im titel ihres schlüssel
songs zusammenarbeit funktioniert nicht
das klingt provokativ und gut
von den sparks hat mir mit einem sehr
netten e mail einen ersten song
geschickt dazu die aufforderung du
kannst damit machen was immer du
möchtest alles ist möglich
es war das icon operations and work wir
waren total perplex und dachten das ist
er verrückt mehr verstanden es als eine
aufforderung zum spiel wir hatten
dieselbe wellenlänge
deshalb hat die zusammenarbeit so gut
funktioniert ironisch unangepasst
exzentrisch das war des parks schon
immer ob sie nun glam rock spielten oder
später sind die pop ihren stil ließen
sie sich nie von trends diktieren
den größten hit landeten die kalifornier
mit westend bgf von bose was vor 40
jahren als die jungs von franz ferdinand
noch im strampelanzug steckten
heute sind es die indie rocker aus
glasgow die vor massen spielen
sie selbst bewundern die box deshalb
stehen die beiden bands bereits seit
zehn jahren miteinander in kontakt
daraus hat sich ffs entwickelt ein
projekt das nicht nur die initialen der
bands vereint sondern auch ihre stil
sind die klänge und indie-rock
verschmelzen zu einem neuen ganzen wir
haben die songs die sie uns zugeschickt
haben genommen
daran gearbeitet und mit unseren ideen
erweitert wir dachten
entweder werden sie beleidigt sein oder
wir werden richtig gut zusammenarbeiten
glücklicherweise war das zweite parks
weiß nicht gewohnt mit anderen leuten
zusammen lieder zu schreiben
um ehrlich zu sein war es bis anhin
immer so dass wir die songs geschrieben
haben und jemand anders oder lassen sie
visionen hat das war für uns die erste
wahre zusammenarbeit
das spannendste dabei war ich zu wissen
wie das endprodukt sein wird
nun ist das gemeinsame album erschienen
der schlüsselsong kokettiert die
zusammenarbeit funktioniert über
generationen und einen ozean hinweg